The
idiom “You can’t have your cake and eat
it too” deliciously illustrates the concept
of making trade-offs and realizing that you
can’t have something if you have another.
The phrase is often used when referring to
compromises and alludes to making a choice
between two options that could never be reconciled.
In other words, the two options that are mutually
exclusive.
Other cultures have adopted the spirit of
this phrase to fit into their own languages.
For example, in Russian the (translated) phrase
is “You can’t sit on two chairs.”
In German, the saying goes “You can’t
dance at two weddings.”
In Yiddish, the adage goes much like the German,
except “one tuchis” is added on to the
end.
Tuchis is Yiddish for backside, or less delicately,
the butt; so, “You can’t sit on two chairs
with the same butt.”
Of course, with the cake expression…
I mean, it’s your cake; why can’t you
eat it too?
Surely that can’t be the original expression,
as it doesn’t make sense as written.
So where did this expression come from?
The phrase was actually used as early as 1538
in a letter from Thomas Howard, the third
Duke of Norfolk, to Thomas Cromwell, chief
minister to King Henry VIII.
In the letter, found and archived by British
History Online, Duke of Norfolk writes:
I require you to send me, by this bearer,
my will, which ye have sealed in a box.
I must alter things therein, for my substance
in money and plate is not so good now by 2,000l.,
“a man can not have his cake and eat his
cake.”
The idiom was later published in A Dialogue
Conteynyng Prouerbes and Epigrammes by John
Heywood in 1562.
Heywood switches the clauses so it reads,
“Wolde ye bothe eate your cake, and haue
your cake?”
(Several other well-known phrases or “figures
of speech” have been attributed to Heywood,
including “two heads are better than one”
and “Rome was not built in a day.”)
Over the next few hundred years, the phrase
regularly showed up in books, plays, and other
writings.
For instance, in 1738, the phrase showed up
in Jonathan Swift’s political satire “Polite
Conversation” when the character Lady Answerall
exclaims, “She cannot eat her cake and have
her cake.”
According to the New York Times, Swift’s
plays were well-known at the time for mocking
and satirizing language.
It appears that, with Swift’s use of “cake,”
he was in fact commenting on the silliness
of the phrase.
Linguists have debated for years over the
proper order of the verb phrases.
Up until the 19th and 20th centuries, more
often than not, the proverb would read in
some variation of “You can’t EAT your
cake and HAVE it too,” which of course makes
a tad more sense than the modern version;
though in the end, the basic sentiment is
the same- once you eat your cake, no more
cake!
But according to Google Ngram Viewer (a handy
tracker of usage of phrases in published works
over time), somewhere between 1938 and 1939,
the percentages switch and “You can’t
HAVE your cake and EAT it too” became more
prevalent.
Right around this time, President Franklin
D. Roosevelt used the now less common version
of the proverb in his 1940 State of the Union
address when referring to the need to increase
spending for national defense:
As will appear in the annual budget tomorrow,
the only important increase in any part of
the budget is the estimate for national defense.
Practically all other important items show
a reduction.
But you know, you can’t eat your cake and
have it too.
As alluded too above, some linguists have
insisted that “Have…Eat” iteration is
not correct due to the actual plausibility
of the statement.
You, in fact, can have your cake and then
eat it.
That isn’t impossible, therefore it negates
what the actual idiom stands for, not unlike
the common error of saying, “I could care
less!” when one means “could not care
less.”
On the other hand, eating it and, then, having
it is impossible and absurd, hence why this
statement is in fact the correct turn of phrase.
Despite the “Have…Eat” version being
more prevalent in today’s society, one amateur
linguist in particular insisted on using the
“correct” version in a manifesto he wrote.
That person was Theodore J. Kaczynski, aka
the Unabomber.
“The Unabomber” had been mailing and placing
homemade bombs aimed at maiming people who
were involved with modern technologies since
1978.
The FBI had been trying to track him down
for decades.
Finally, in April 1995, the FBI had a break
in the case when the Unabomber’s manifesto
entitled “Industrial Society and its Future”
was sent to major publications across the
country and was, under the threat of violence,
demanded to be released to the public.
If it was with conditions met, he promised
to stop his bombings.
In September 1995, it was published in the
New York Times and Washington Post.
In it, he derides that the industrial revolution
has been a “disaster for the human race”
and calls for a “revolution against technology.”
Additionally, he provides this phrase: “As
for the negative consequences of eliminating
industrial society — well, you can’t eat
your cake and have it too — to gain one
thing you have to sacrifice another.”
Upon seeing this phrasing in the morning paper,
David Kaczynski finally decided his wife might
be right and his brother really might be the
Unabomber.
For their whole lives, their mother would
correct them and insist that this was the
correct usage of the phrase.
This and other similarities in Ted’s writing
style and his political beliefs, convinced
David he needed to speak up.
David passed this information, along with
old family letters demonstrating Ted’s writing
style, to the FBI who employed forensic linguistics
to compare the manifesto to other pieces of
writing Ted had given to his family.
This information, and other stylistic evidence,
convinced a judge to submit a search warrant.
On April 3, 1996, Ted Kaczynski was arrested
by the FBI at his cabin deep in the woods
of Montana.
His own demand to be heard did him in.
As the Unabomber would say, you can’t eat
your cake and have it too.